tell me the best thing about Hillary
Clinton the best thing about Hillary
Clinton is that she's Hillary Clinton
she spent ah you know nearly three
decades in public service her life has
been scrutinized she has survived two
incredibly embarrassing grueling things
the scandal involving a husband and a
loss in a presidential primary when
someone survives humiliations like that
and manages to thrive it says something
fundamental about who they are and I
think more than anything else that
Hillary Clinton's character is a
reflection of her experiences there we
know who Hillary Clinton is there's no
mystery about her anymore is there no
mystery though because I do find that
she's been in it for so long that what
you're saying is her best thing is also
her worst thing we're gonna get to that
in a second but to me it's almost like
she's been around so long she's been
part of the Machine so long obviously
was the first lady was Secretary of
State was a senator now has run now for
the second time that she's so part of
the machine that what I think we
recognize about her is also what we
don't know about her like what's really
driving the desire after all this time
to be part of it you know you know
that's a question that the press asks
all the time I don't think it matters to
voters a lot here's a secret about
Hillary Clinton it might not be obvious
but someone who has survived what she
has survived in public life is beholden
to no one you might think she's
beholding the Wall Street but it's not
true
she's beholden to no one which is why
she can do pretty much anything she
wants so what about all these people
that say well she's taking all this
money and there's money from foreign
governments and etc and all the money
from going on Saks and the speeches and
all that and they made 24 million in the
last six months or something or whatever
that number is they say well they're
they're beholden to all these people how
could she be beholding to all these
people how could anybody be beholding
all these people but you know that's not
to say that that the Clintons generally
don't make mistakes in judgment of
course they do yeah all that is to say
that that she personally has the freedom
of action to do whatever she wants in
politics to say whatever she wants
primarily to curate a public image in a
way that that really no other candidate